[Music]
we can end it on the video
the video that i sent what's your name
sir oh yeah yeah oh my
oh my god bro oh my god
it's [ __ ]
okay here we go someone here this guy is
this
private property if i put my hands on
him
you gotta be going to jail don't worry
you're on you're on camera
i'm not gonna put my hands on you but
why do you keep talking to me sir
i ask you to leave me alone you come out
here being disrespectful all right you
think disrespectful you're at a funeral
home all right we understand you
should've
you should have just said who the truck
but you come out ahead getting all
people's faces like we won't knock you
the [ __ ] out
hey shut up man
state your name what's your name
right now you want to walk off
what's your name what's your name sir my
name is these
please what sir
i've never seen i mean that one
when you got me that was good but this i
feel like this takes
this takes first place i've never seen
one that good before
he like can't believe it's not he can't
believe it
he can't believe he got him he's just
these these what sir
the confidence these what
[Music]
these what dude
don't [ __ ] with delivery drivers man i
do i don't think people understand the
world does not give a [ __ ]
about delivery drivers but they everyone
wants them to do their job it's like i
know this [ __ ]
this is like some weird goofy thing
where he has to put the truck somewhere
and he doesn't know where the [ __ ] to
put it
this guy comes like you're on private
property right right right right there
it's like bro shut the [ __ ] up i'll be
out of here in 10 minutes
and then you get this what's your name
sir my name is these these what sir
these nuts
they can't believe it
what did the white guy say he's like ah
good one
a good one bro you know you oh my god
dude
these what he's what he's not
i gotta hear it one more time dude he's
like in his [ __ ] face
i know the chin to shoulder these
my name is deez what's your name sir my
name is these
these ones
[Laughter]
all right dude i gotta i gotta piss my
ass off
all right guys you in the bone zone guys
tmgpod.com pick up some merch
that broke [ __ ] hoodie that i showed
that's also in black it's super dope and
there's just
a bunch of dope [ __ ] so tmgpod.com yeah
uh for all for all the um people out
there that want to support the one
percent boys
yeah all right all right
you